[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi ah buckets for me though it's my
little bit yes alright they heard a name
oh my music did your mom send cookies
uh yeah among some other things just be
give me a necklace that I wanted from
nylon for Kwanzaa you guys give gifts
for Kwanzaa you try to find ways to
fight the system whenever we can what
the hello mom yes could you flip the
phone around I can't hear you you're
speaking into the earpiece you need to
be speaking into the mouthpiece so flip
the phone I know sweetie little walnut
Milo can you ask your mom about the
cookie recipe shut up yes I will mom
question this necklace thing I really
like the one you sent but it's just not
the one I actually wanted to win I know
it's not the one you wanted but this one
is from your great-grandmother and she'd
be happy to see you wear it it's nice no
it's very nice I'm not saying it's not
nice it's just that I was going for a
certain look what is this [ __ ] are the
cinnamon yes mom I am eating that is
such a weird question please stop asking
that I love you I'll talk to you later
okay now if I can replicate this formula
did you hang up yes bond without getting
the recipe oh I'll have to call her back
I'm your phone no you stop it attitude
okay I need to get my hand on these
recipes those cookies trying to ask you
is pointless
considering you only know how to make
eggs you're on that damn tumblr yes Paul
I'm on tumblr who or what are you
looking at well Marvel fandom I'm
winning nudity inspirational posts in
Leila why hello Wyatt Instagram mom
she's not an Instagram model she's a
real model and she's so cool I don't
know she's just so comfortable with
herself and really chill and really cool
with being new
yes she is stop okay she's just perfect
and she's super smart she her blog one
of my Bukowski inspired poems run a
little too much makeup if you ask me she
just wants to be flawless in pictures
nothing wrong with that you know has
flawless skin so what's the letter after
T in the alphabet you mean no not me you
you're the letter the letter U oh I see
what you did or Yoko no your best well
why don't you get ready I'm going to
party baby W is spinning in layaway
everything so we're gonna be good and be
best friends and travel the world
together it'll be great alright what are
you doing with my phone calling off oh
hello mrs. right young man press okay
all right no about those cookies Oh Paul
I'm not giving you my cook yeah
[Music]
my load made it yeah aw thank you so
much for coming on supporting me
probably date you're ready something
moves I learned in the DJ academy okay
hey um bwok
yes Colin do I look Milo you worry but a
queen amongst us and I just really think
that yeah
duty calls okay we'll listen you kill it
have fun um I think I see somebody I
know so I just wanted to go sing hi okay
yeah hey bye
this one I'll see you later see ya hey
Layla hey do I know you
um yeah I'm Milo we follow each other on
tumblr oh yeah I recognize you
yeah you're the one that writes all
those really weird things about dad I
mean I they're not about that per se
they're kind of subjective they could be
about life yeah but they're all Charles
Bukowski
a hobo wedding what
Charles Bukowski I thought you knew him
since you Ferb logged a couple of his
poems you know I don't know I literally
just reblog whatever let's go on the
page like I don't know where half that
stuff comes from oh yeah okay yeah what
is that
what are you come on quick question yeah
do you have any code yeah like coca-cola
no like blow like cocaine light no no I
don't know I don't I don't do cocaine no
worries school um Maria
can you please go and find me some coke
yes I got you thank you so much I love
you think you like you thank you Matt um
yes so can I do anything for you ones
like a selfie wanna like chill
oh yeah I'll take selfie you let's take
a selfie okay sounds good yeah Sony
phones a little broke
really nice necklace by the way ah thank
you the company's paying me to wear it
okay
nice to meet you it was nice to meet you
too bye meelo it's up it's Milo okay you
look great so do you know who Charles
Bukowski is he sounds super hot hey I
found I was in these cookies oh yeah
what it's meant a hint of mint yeah I
told you that forgot she had a garden
what is Jam yeah now I can make these
all the time yeah yeah for sure how's me
delaila
um honestly she was awful yeah she was
kind of mean and not that smart
oh yeah I'm sorry puddin okay I know
what it's like to find out your heroes a
day ya know it's like in my fourth
birthday party when I took off
spider-man's mask and it was really just
my aunt Lysa and a bald cat those
situations can be disappointing and very
confusing yeah I guess but you know what
she wasn't even a hero to me she wasn't
like Condoleezza Rice or Will Smith
you just all should be a nice friend
somebody I could kick it with for once
besides you guys of course
I want to see Sophie yeah all right you
are going to barf hmm you know someone
asked me who do I want to hang out with
based on this very real unplanned on
Photoshop picture would definitely be
you you're the cool one
you're the real one homegrown in Philly
with just a little dash of some special
it's hard to figure out you are your
mom's cookies thank you and they are so
tasty you want some girl thinking
they're delicious
hey see Mama's cookies put them in a box
hey taste his mama's cookies just get
him while they're hot that sounds really
in a pervasive Mama's cookies your mom's
cookies taste really good stop it's a
really inappropriate song what show is
it okay oh man this is Mama's cookies
put them in a box
Casey Mama's cookies get them while
they're hot
this is Mama's cookies they came with
the note this is Mama's cookies eat up
man up